discussion Devred on se poursuivre entre
la Russie et les États-Unis après la
rencontre virtuelle entre Vladimir
Poutine et Giovanni hier après-midi 2h
Deschamps sur les tensions entre
l'Occident et Moscou notamment sur
l'Ukraine depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant Washington et ses alliés
accuse la Russie de vouloir envahir
l'Ukraine le chef de la Maison Blanche a
menacé la Russie de forte sanction en
cas de d'escalade en Ukraine Vladimir
Poutine il y a dénoncé des tentatives de
l'OTAN je cite d'exploiter le territoire
ukrainien elle est précision de notre
correspondant à Washington Thomas bonnet
du côté de Washington on évoque cette
discussion comme très direct avec des
échanges très franc entre les présidents
Joe Biden est Vladimir Poutine un
communiqué a été publié à l'issue de
cette discussion un communiqué assez
succincte avec un thon et relativement
ferme où on apprend que Joe Bayonne a
averti Vladimir Poutine qu'il y aurait
des sanctions en cas d'agression de la
Russie contre l'Ukraine et puis une
conférence de presse a été organisé à la
maison blanche avec le conseiller à la
sécurité nationale de Joe Biden Jack
Sullivan qui a plus détaillée justement
elle les menaces proférées lors de cet
entretien elle part Washington je
propose de l'écouter à réaffirmer le
soutien américain à la souveraineté est
à l'intégrité territoriale de l'Ukraine
il a déclaré son détour président
Poutine que si la Russie envahissait
l'Ukraine les États-Unis et nos alliés
européen répondrai par des mesures
d'économie fort nous fournirons du
matériel défensif supplémentaire aux
ukrainien en plus de ce que nous
fournissons déjà et nous renforceront
les alliés de l'OTAN sur l' avec des
capacité supplémentaire en réponse à une
telle escalade il a également déclarer
au président Poutine qu'il existe une
autre option la désescalader la
diplomatie
pas à détailler les mesures économiques
tu pourrais prendre Washington en cas
d'agissement russe il a également
expliqué qu'il n'y avait eu aucun
engagement de la part du président
américain sur une éventuelle adhésion de
l'Ukraine au sein de l'OTAN et puis Jack
Sullivan a également fixé ce qui
ressemble à une ligne rouge de la part
de Washington à savoir donc une invasion
du territoire ukrainien elle par la
Russie là également été question lors de
cette conférence de presse du gazoduc
Nord Stream deux qui selon Washington
pour être utilisé comme un levier par
les Occidentaux à 6 Vladimir Poutine dit
il veut que le gazoduc soit en fonction
il devrait ne pas vouloir prendre le
risque d'envahir l'Ukraine tout en
expliquant qu'il y avait des contacts
réguliers entre les autorités
américaines et les autorités allemande
sur ce sujet on sait que Joe Bayonne
ensuite téléphoner à ses alliés européen
pour débriefé la conversation qui l'a vu
avec Vladimir putin un communiqué hammam
été publié pour que les Européens
affirme a qu'ils étaient attachés à
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Ukraine et
puis c'est mercredi que je Bayonne
devrait s'entretenir avec le président
ukrainien là encore pour revenir sur les
différents éléments qui ont été abordés
lors de cet échange avec Vladimir
Poutine on sait d'ailleurs que les
représentants ukrainien ont participé à
alimenter le climat alarmiste qui règne
dans les médias américain puisque encore
il y a quelques heures c'est le Ministre
ukrainien de la défense qui répondait à
l'interview sur l'antenne de CNN ou
l'expliquer que si la Russie venait à
envahir l'Ukraine il s'agirait je cite
d'un massacre semble